Prüfung Telc & Goethe
Start Deutsch 1
Das Komplette Vokabular mit Dialogen
Lektion 5
49 Wörter
Los geht's!
der Verkäufer – die Verkäufer
die Kleidung
der/die/das erste, zweite, dritte, vierte…
günstig
Meine Mutter ist Verkäuferin im Kaufhaus.
Wo finde ich Kleidung?
Jacken im ersten, Jeans im zweiten Stock.
Dort gibt es auch günstige Angebote.
der Jugendliche – die Jugendlichen
die Frau – die Frauen
Jugendliche kaufen hier gern ein.
Ja. Und es hat mehr Frauen als Männer.
kaufen
die Tasche – die Taschen
kosten
mehr
Ich kaufe mir eine neue Tasche.
Wie viel kostet sie?
115 Euro.
Und diese?
Diese Tasche kostet 50 Euro mehr.
der Preis – die Preise
dürfen
100 = hundert / einhundert
101 = hunderteins
200 = zweihundert
nichts
Die Preise hier sind sehr hoch.
Sie darf nicht mehr als 100 Euro kosten.
Hier kaufe ich nichts.
Der Laden gefällt mir nicht.
das Angebot – die Angebote
dann
Heute sind Sportschuhe im Angebot.
Ich muss noch schnell zur Toilette,
dann komme ich.
die Toilette – die Toiletten
die Treppe – die Treppen
die Dame – die Damen
nichts
Wo ist die Toilette, bitte?
Die Toilette?
Die Treppe hoch und dann links.
An der Tür steht "Damen" geschrieben.
Danke vielmals! Entschuldigung!
Das macht nichts.
die Farbe – die Farben
schwarz
weiß
grau
rot
blau
gelb
grün
braun
Welche Farbe möchten Sie?
Rot gefällt mir gut.
was für ein…
lang
Was für eine schöne Jeans.
Aber sie ist mir zu lang.
billig
Sie – Ihnen (Dativ)
anbieten
anderer/andere/anderes
Die Jacke kostet nur 10 Euro!
Die ist aber billig!
Ich kann Ihnen auch diese Jacke anbieten.
Nein, ich möchte die andere.
die Größe
für
so … wie (so groß wie)
Haben Sie Größe 40?
Ist die Jacke für Sie?
Nein, für meinen Mann.
Er ist so groß wie ich.
helfen
der Kunde – die Kunden
Können Sie mir helfen?
Einen Moment, bitte. Ich habe eine Kundin.
dieser, diese, dieses da
bezahlen
die Kasse
Ich nehme diese da.
Wo muss ich bezahlen?
Zahlen Sie bitte an der Kasse.
Weiter geht´s im nächsten Video!